it's almost time for the server
[Applause]
what is it oh
you're the one who saved father armin
the other half of the stone tablet in
the cathedral i didn't even know it was
half a tablet to begin with
the other half of the stone tablet in
the cathedral i didn't even know it was
half a tablet to begin with
i see a lot of adventurers around these
days
so got any news
this looks a bit heavy
the stone tablet in the cathedral oh
the slab engraved with something about
the ark right kind of naive to believe a
made-up story like that
anything exciting going on today
you're an adventurer looking for the ark
lord of all god
how do you like pride home events we're
having today
[Music]
good job every time you fill out the
tome the association will reward you
brothers and sisters
let us pray
please tell us a piece of tablet what
are you seeking the ark you're like
ruden
did you find anything special
you'd think if there was a clue to the
ark there someone would have found it
already
hmm
i wonder what an area is doing
[Music]
hello adventurer
how can i help you
hi there
what can i do for you
the tablet about the ark
[Music]
the stone masons of log hill might be
able to help
[Music]